hello there so we have some great news
for the house of dragons season two so
apparently henry cavill and elizabeth
olsen have rumored to be in season two
of the house of dragon now both of these
people are very very talented and always
give such a good performance for
whatever role they're playing and i can
actually see them fit in this universe
really well and i'll explain why so this
picture of henry cavill here is of him
playing gerald in the witcher now if you
guys aren't familiar with the witcher
you would have saw this image and you
could have assumed this was straight up
game of thrones like honestly he looks
like a targaryen here with the long
flowing hair and he kind of even looks
like matt smith's character damon from
house of dragon so his look can easily
fit game of thrones but what do you guys
think do you think we'll see them in
season 2 and do you think there would be
a good cast choice if so what character
do you think they could play and if you
haven't already please do consider
subscribing thanks for watching guys